if later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend
[Music]
ready sound of a sewage hey what's going
on guys
so every now and then when I get super
stressed out from work and I feel like
my whole world is crashing down on me I
like to go back home and by home I mean
Sacramento California that's my hometown
not with it still to go back because it
kind of like resets my batteries I get
to see family I get to see my friends
and kind of reconnect with what what I
call my roots anyways and it just really
helps me to get things in perspective
and I'm not that much of a party animal
I'm not outside you know drinking 24/7
getting drunk you know sucking a lot of
difference but as you guys know in
Sacramento there is a State Fair that
goes down every year if you guys don't
know what the State Fair is you
obviously have no friends but I used to
go to the State Fair almost every year
when I was younger but you know the past
four to five years I don't think I've
really gone once so it's been a minute
for me since I've been there but the
main reason why I stopped going is
because there was a lot of ghetto
[ __ ] there now the State Fair
for me like I haven't been there in a
while has grown a lot like the
attendance rate is huge it's got to the
point whether it was like this back back
lot for where we were supposed to park
our cars and my fat ass park all the way
narnia [ __ ] but the dope thing was the
State Fair had like the Elk Grove
Unified School District buses pick us up
so I thought that was a little odd I
felt like I was high school again when I
was trying to sit in the back with all
the cool kids remember that she had all
the cool kids sat in the back and if you
were losing you sat in the front I was I
was a loser ain't nobody wanted to sit
next to me on the bus and I don't think
it was because I wasn't cool is I was
really fat that took up like 3/4 of the
city when I sat on the bus i sat next to
everybody now any kind of State Fair as
you guys well know is all about the food
if you are a hardcore vegan and you
don't believe in eating meat I
completely understand but why the [ __ ]
would you ever go to a State Fair every
animal on earth is gonna be deep-fried
and murdered there so you would just be
screaming the whole time
there's like 7,000 deep fried or roasted
turkey legs which I don't even
understand how many turkeys you killed
to just take off the legs but you a
monster well now when you guys go to a
State Fair understand that you will not
be able to eat everything because
there's a lot of food so make sure you
know what exactly what you want for
example we wanted the lobster fried you
know the weird [ __ ] was like when we
first ordered the fries first of all it
took about 45 [ __ ] minutes to even get
it and then when we finally got it they
just gave us a bucket of fries go ask
there's a lobster that we did ask for
regular fries oh [ __ ] what the hell but
you know they kind of made up for it
because those fries wasn't looking mom
sure there it had huge chunks of lobster
has his delicious cream sauce on top of
that I think there was green onions and
this just uh-huh I forgot how much it
cost but I think it was roughly around
$12 but for the amount of lobster and
fries that you've got in the ratio was
super good it was well worth it it was
salty crunchy creamy seafoody it's
exactly what I wanted
wow that sounded like a [ __ ] load not
that I will know I've never had I've
heard this is going really weird I don't
I remember when I was younger I looked
forward to going to the State Fair every
year even though it was hot it didn't
matter I knew that was gonna be dope as
food there was gonna be some hot ass
chick with some shorter shorts that I
was too nervous to talk to so I'll just
look at them from a distance like a
pervert and then you know remember the
face and touch myself later that night
but it was a really great experience for
me to go back because not only wasn't
nostalgic I got to go ahead and
reconnect with a lot of my friends that
I haven't seen in a while and you know
for me too like if you and I have a
great connection and we are friends from
the get-go and you guys have been there
for me for since day one best believe it
you and I will be friends until you know
you don't want to be I'm not that easy
to get rid of I know for a lot of you
guys when you guys went off to college
you lost connection with a lot of your
high school friends for me it wasn't
like that the friends that were
important to me and really helped build
Who I am today you know they're very
near and dear to my heart I'm not gonna
just up and leave them and just forget
about them just because I move somewhere
else I don't think friendship works out
that way so if you guys truly connect to
your people around you like from
elementary school to junior high to even
high school make sure you keep those
people around because they were with you
from day one and if they stuck with you
since day one you should be respectful
enough to give that love back I'm not
sure if I mentioned this to you guys
before but before I left
to go do YouTube and stuff like that and
leave la decided to leave college I sold
all my stuff buy so much shoes I sold a
lot of other things so I could have cash
to do what I want to do but there were
certain things I couldn't afford one of
the things I couldn't afford was there's
24 to 70 sigma lens which I still use
today in a lot of my vlogs and then my
friends kind of like chipped in to buy
that lens from me and it was like $1000
in mind you like you know none of us was
really balling there wasn't one single
person that was gonna buy me that gift
but my best friend gobble came in and he
asked people to chip in for me before I
left to LA and you know when I got that
gift you know I didn't tear up in front
of it when I went home I teared up
because you know growing up for me like
in all honesty it was hard for me to
make friends and I'm not talking about
like acquaintances I'm talking about
real friends because in high school it's
all about kind of molding to what
everybody else wanted now it was hard
for me to do that even when I did it
sometimes it just didn't fit and because
for me I chose to be myself I was very
abrasive towards other people people
didn't understand like we know why would
you want to be yourself when you could
just be part of a clique and I didn't
have that so being able to be in a
position where before I left it kind of
really set in stone that I grew up with
a lot of great people that really
influenced me in a very good way and I
was so appreciative that that I you know
when I went home I teared up a little
bit because because I think at that
moment I decided to tell myself that I
was not gonna come back to Sacramento
loser and I wasn't gonna come back as a
failure specifically because when they
got me something like that it put a bit
of weight in my shoulder in the sense of
this is an embodiment of them believing
in you so if you don't believe in
yourself that much how can you come back
home without accomplishing something
maybe I was just potaters believe me I
don't usually grab things
[Music]